Oops, I forgot to turn the sound on.
Hold on.
I didn't set up anything.
Okay, I set it up.
Welcome,
everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome back to Oblivion.
Yeah!
What
did we do last time?
Welcome.
Can I have your blessing to marry Etina?
No!
It goes against her parole!
She cannot get married!
She cannot have a relationship.
Despite everything, you're still such a kind soul.
What did I do?
I don't think I'm so kind.
I'm an evil ghost, actually.
Did you not see the title of the stream?
Some people are probably like, what are you talking about?
Mom in Italy simulator.
What does that mean?
It's something I talked about.
Title may be confusing the non-members.
I'm already... I'm working on it!
I'm talking about it!
Give me a second!
Jeez!
Oh, gosh!
No, I'm gonna leave you guys hanging, maybe.
Wee!
Thank you for the super time!
Thank you!
I'm still trying to remember what happened last stream.
Evil ghost haunt me tonight.
I think he was mean just looking at her in that corner.
Hehehehehehe.
Yeah!
Hehehehehe!
Anyway...
Um...
Uh...
I told this story last night in a members stream.
But, um...
My mom went to Italy...
My mom went to Italy recently...
And...
Um...
Well, what she told me a couple months ago that she was going...
She's like, I'm going with a tour group with my friends.
And I was like...
Okay!
Have fun, mom!
But also be careful.
Because my...
My...
Impression of Italy...
Is that one lady on TikTok that goes...
Attention, pickpocket!
And I was like...
Be careful of the pickpockets, mom.
And she's like...
Okay!
I got a special purse!
I got a special purse, so...
I'll be fine!
And I was like...
Okay!
And...
She texted me Wednesday...
And she said...
I'm leaving for Italy!
And I said...
Okay!
Have fun!
And then Thursday, she texted me and she said...
I just landed in Italy!
And I said...
Okay!
Be safe!
And Friday...
I get a text from an unknown number that says...
This is mom!
Not a scam!
My phone and my bag got pickpocketed!
Casey!
Thank you so much for the vibe!
Good to take you!
Attention, pickpocket!
I'm so sorry!
I'm not singing right now because of my voice!
But Happy Birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy,
happy birthday!
You're like, oh, I wonder if this is how she felt... when she got her money stolen.
Maybe I think it's better than five gifted.
And it's not that I'm laughing about my mom getting pickpocketed.
I'm laughing about how fast it happened.
I'm laughing about how she went and she was there for one day and it happened.
It's so funny, Gray Fox got her, truly.
Truly, truly.
One day, she couldn't even last a single day.
Robbing American tourists is the number one European pastime.
Sorry, your mom had to learn through the culturally immersive way.
I told her to be careful.
This is not a scam.
14 months are not pickpockets.
Mel-chan, thank you.
Also, Tree goes, happy early birthday.
Now I can't remember, though, what we did last stream.
Also, V, thank you so much for the super chat.
You have violated the law.
One twist would be if your mom texts you in stream and she's turned to a thrilling life of pickpocketing on her own.
Yeah.
But knowing my mom is like such an easy target.
My mom's a really, really easy target.
So...
Honestly, I'm not so surprised.
Lost in the store, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Rikadan, welcome back.
Thank you.
Steals 100 gold.
Thinking of you, mama.
Exactly.
Just like Italy, mamma mia.
Hold on.
You guys want some ASMR...
Um...
Opening a can of coffee ASMR?
Would you like that?
Yes?
Let me turn off the music.
Can you hear that?
Can you hear the can?
Okay.
I'm gonna open it.
I...
I can't get my finger under it.
That was clean!
Ah, nice!
Mmm...
Yummy coffee.
And this one is made with the oat milk, so it's so...
Delicioso.
Sounds like beer?
I tried beer.
I don't really like it.
Lucky, thanks for the gift.
Dude!
It was really hot.
Make you think of, uh...
Opening up, uh...
Can of Coke on a hot day.
Congratulations on successfully opening coffee.
Thank you, beer o'clock.
Everybody, don't go swimming now, okay?
Wait.
Which way?
No, order of operations.
No s...
Wait.
Uh...
It was beer after swim.
Don't swim and drink.
Don't drink and swim, everybody.
You'll get a...
A SUI.
Swimming under the influence.
Yeah.
Hope you guys have fun pickpocketing tonight.
It's my birthday!
Bye!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Coffee opening level has increased.
Yes.
Why does a SUI sound like a...
Like something...
You would get during naughty time.
A sui!
Sounds like an infection.
No, that's what I'm saying.
Like a disease.
SUI.
Okay.
Maybe we should just...
Continue the game and see where we left off.
There is one thing I want to do today.
I want to finally kill those people.
And finish that one quest.
With the guy.
We're eating our level 7.
Guys, you know what's hilarious is...
I would be in Japan.
Where...
What was I doing here?
How do I play this game again?
I'm gonna...
I'm standing here.
I'm gonna get attacked by a crab.
Um...
I bought a brand new movie on Blu-Ray, Shrinkwreck, and everything.
Guess what?
The darn thing was skip and freezing.
Ew.
Is it your player?
Thieves Guild.
Oh yeah, we did do that, didn't we?
Um...
But while I was in Japan, there were so many...
ET...
T-shirts.
And I just...
I couldn't...
I wanted to buy so many of them.
Because what are the odds?
What are the odds?
That...
I create ET that...
And then ET is popular again.
ET phone home.
Oh.
Who are you?
ET phone home.
It is one phone call...
After getting in jail.
So we are...
What time is it?
Oh gosh, how do I see you again?
Oh, I just did something.
I clicked C for clock.
Maybe T for time.
Oh, there we go.
It is 2 AM.
Good to see you again.
C for cast.
Oh.
Oh, I have no finds and bounty.
I'm okay, I think.
Shadow hide you.
Oh, puny.
I think these were the...
Oh yeah, I killed your captain.
I remember doing that.
Are you gonna sing?
Oh hey, sweet lady of mine.
Oh, I'll see you again.
Yes, I'll see you again.
Sweet lady of mine.
We were so fine.
Gosh, I...
I almost ran out of breath in that one.
I was just trying to keep up with him.
Okay.
The guy we were trying to murder...
Was in...
Wait, what's going on here?
Why is it so foggy?
I can't see anything.
I swear I've run up and down this city.
Have I not?
Maybe not.
Oh wait, this is me!
Oh, this is...
I thought I was zooming into here.
Into here.
What are these?
Sorry, it's gonna take me a second to get back up to...
Get back up to speed of where we are and how to play this game.
Try to clean your glasses.
I got new glasses!
But I think they're too strong.
I feel like I'm in a fishbowl every time I put them on.
Where they are.
The one where you rob the church.
Steal the bust.
Of...
Latasa Indaris.
From...
Cheyendoll.
That's right!
We need like a buttload of money.
Because...
I want to buy that haunted house.
LASIK gang...
Scary!
Only a hundred coins?
That's what I'm thinking too.
Hold on, let's go back to... What was it?
Paranoia?
Yeah.
One thousand septums.
Okay.
Yes.
And it's night time, so this is perfect.
We'll just fast travel.
Minton Heights.
Yeah, we gotta kill the toadiest sextiers.
Is it raining?
Perfect.
The rain will wash away the blood.
Wait.
In here?
West Weild.
No.
Get me inside the city.
Please.
Where do I go inside the city?
West Weild.
Where do I get inside the city?
Oh?
I'm lost.
Why is this so confusing?
You are inside.
SkinGrad is weird.
Is it?
Am I inside?
Maybe now I'm outside?
I'm not gonna get... Wait.
Why is it looking...
It's already 6am?
I think I missed my chance...
To kill in the dark.
Everybody's gonna be awake in like...
An hour.
Wait.
Maybe if I go up here...
We'll sleep with your stream on...
Good night, Tolkien.
Good night.
Thank you.
That's right.
I'm a sniper.
Everybody remember that?
Oh, I thought that was a...
Open portal for a second.
I don't think Elder Scrolls people are that early.
They are.
I remember.
Okay.
We're at the farm.
I know where we are.
I remember.
These horses are not mine.
What are the sheep doing?
Oh.
That guy's leading them.
Who are you?
He doesn't want...
He does not want anything to do with me.
You guys are lagging behind.
Sheep.
They're so slow.
What's that over there?
That's not a portal, is it?
Why is he four foot three?
Etina is just huge.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, he's your sheep.
He's the worst herder ever.
He's just...
They'll never catch a sheep.
I wonder where they're going anyway.
Okay.
We have a duty.
Look, they're already up and at them.
Who are you?
Tilmo.
You need to see Ugak if you want to buy a horse.
She's inside.
Nah, I have a better horse.
Rumors.
Magra Mogak runs a fine establishment at the Two Sisters Lodge.
And her sister has some quality horses.
Oh.
Stop talking.
Okay.
How are you?
He says, I haven't had my coffee yet.
Everybody's so rude in this game.
Wait a second.
I'm inside.
Good morning.
Hello.
Okay.
We are inside.
Now I just have to murder.
Tutius Sextius.
He lives there.
I remember his house.
He's actually got quite a nice looking house.
Oh, I can go in.
Wait, who are you?
A coin for an old beggar.
Nah.
Oh wait, but he'll tell me the secrets of stealing.
How do I put my weapon away again?
Oh, there we go.
Come in unassuming.
Okay.
Do you guys think I still remember how to pickpocket?
I mean...
Lick...
No.
Why do I do this every time?
How goes it?
Hello.
Do you think anybody will hear his screams?
I was gonna say...
Lock pick.
Oh, golly.
How are you?
Go ahead, please.
Um...
Rumors.
Oh, I can't say about Glarther.
Cannot say.
Mr. Freud needs to be consulted.
No!
That guy's a hack.
Hey, you're the one they call the hero of Kvatch, aren't you?
The one that closed the oblivion gate and saved the city.
Yeah.
So you should trust me.
Good day.
F5 is quick save?
Right?
Thank you.
Now we have to wait for him to forget about us.
And we're just gonna stay up here, you know?
And make it so that he can't see us.
And then we'll get that sneak bonus for our...
For the first shot.
My middle name is Pocket.
I don't believe you.
So you can add another person who likes Culver's.
Tried a Butter Burger while vacationing in Ohio.
Liked it a lot.
What's your favorite dish there?
I haven't...
Oh my gosh.
I have not been to...
A Culver's in so long.
I do remember liking their Butter Burger though.
I hear Lick Pocking is an epidemic in Italy.
You think I can get him now?
Okay.
I quick saved.
Let's try.
What's going on?
This is the part where you fall down and bleed to death.
Where are you going?
Wait, don't leave.
Don't leave.
Shoot.
Uh oh.
It's all over, Law Breaker.
Your spree is at an end.
I'll take any stolen goods you have.
I didn't steal anything!
Next room is yours.
Pay your fine.
Or I'll haul you away.
I could just pay the gold.
Oh, that's right.
I was going to use the special.
Then pay with your blood.
I think he died.
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
He's still alive.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm stuck.
What's up?
How did he...
How did he live?
Look at him with his little fists up.
You want to die too?
I'll kill this whole city.
Okay.
What was that?
What was the quick load?
Is that one HP?
Someone's been murdered.
What is that guy?
What did I do to you?
I'm just warming up, you pathetic worms.
F9.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's see.
Inventory.
Maybe...
What's the arrow of dispel?
We need like a poison arrow.
I don't think I know how to make them, though.
Hey, Q.
I've seen you.
Let me see your face.
You were the one from my dreams.
Oh my gosh, it's Uriel!
Don't die, Uriel.
Use poison in inventory.
Check if you have any poisons.
In here.
Poison of illness.
I have a poison.
Oh.
Damaged health on...
Self.
I don't think that's what...
Is good.
Wait, this works?
Use it?
Apply it to a weapon.
You put it on the weapons.
So if I use it...
Okay.
If I...
If I use it wrong, I can always reload.
Yes.
Aha!
Okay.
Let's see if this does the job, then.
I also have these, but these are weak.
Weak potions.
Weak poisons.
Weak, weak, weak.
Help!
I'm being attacked!
Oh.
I think because he yells, they hear.
Oops.
They're gonna come in.
Oh, and he laughed.
What?
The bouncy moments in Togos of Chibi Man are the cutest.
Thank you!
Ah!
This guy is...
So...
Beefy!
He's like a cow!
Dagger typically has...
More sneak damage.
Okay.
So if I poison with a dagger, it should be better.
Maybe.
Do I have a dagger?
Probably.
Blade of Woe?
Ah, yeah.
Wait, I used it?
I think it worked.
How do I kill him?
By the Nines of Lines!
Assault!
Ah!
Oh!
He's so...
He is so beefy!
He's so beefy!
Charge your attack.
Okay, hold on.
Let's try again.
He's so beefy!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he blends in with the wall.
For real.
Is my blade of woe the best thing?
I got the katana.
I think it is the best thing I've got.
Suffer thorn?
Where is that?
Oh, this one!
Oh, thank you.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Okay, good.
Good eyes, everybody.
Good eyes.
So how do I charge an attack?
Hold.
Hold the attack button down.
Oh, God.
Thank you, guys.
Alright.
I'm charging.
Uh...
I don't think it's working.
Dang!
This is good, though.
Oh!
I got him.
You think I can leave?
Maybe if I, like, leave out a window, they'll never know it's me.
Go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
There are no windows I can leave.
Oh, shoot.
Can I hide under the bed?
Sleep.
Um...
Shoot.
Wait,
how...
Nobody came.
Uh-oh.
Nope.
Stop right there, criminal scum.
Nobody breaks the law on my watch.
I'm confiscating your stolen goods.
Now pay your fine, or it's off to jail.
I did it!
I didn't!
I didn't rob him!
Ugh!
I feel...
I'm like...
If I keep paying the fines, I'm not gonna make any money, you know?
How...
How am I supposed to make the...
Raise the money I need for the house if I can't kill this guy?
They take your stolen goods, too?
I think I sold all my stolen goods.
So I think I'm okay.
Aww...
Pay the thieves' guild for half the bounty.
What, if I...
Resist?
If I resist and...
I run?
And then I go to the...
Are I doing it at night?
Yeah, maybe.
Resist and go to the thieves' guild.
I would have to run so far.
I would have to go so far.
Okay.
But also, I'm only gonna get paid a thousand.
So, if it's a thousand forty...
Each time I get caught...
Then...
I make no money back.
What does jail...
What is the...
What is the bad side of jail?
I get free food.
Hold on, mister.
I'm having an internal...
Conflict...
In my brain.
That's right.
You lose stats.
A Minto ran...
He ran so far away...
Crime doesn't pay, Minto.
So...
I've committed to this life.
Hope you rot, criminal scum.
Cool.
Let's see what we lose.
My clothes!
Etina, you're indecent.
Average, you say?
I...
I still got it, baby.
Anyone else in here?
No one else?
This looks like it could be exploded.
Oh, see?
She goes right in.
I didn't do it!
Where's my stuff?
I think I should reload.
Well now...
What do we have here?
Caught in the act and no gold.
To pay your fine.
I'm confiscating your stolen goods.
Now it's off to jail with ya.
Then pay with your blood!
What's the matter?
Getting tired?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm...
Here!
Okay, F9.
Where am...
Where does...
Oh, we're back here!
It was all a dream.
Ha!
Okay.
Good morning.
I'll come back for you, Tutius.
I still have to remember where the other two were.
It was all a dream!
Okay, uh...
We're trying to kill...
Where's the other one?
Oh...
Uh...
Center, answer, caves, camps, forts.
That's so boring, though!
Hey!
What is it?
You're the lady that likes...
Necromancy!
What can I do for you?
Are you on my team?
Hmm...
I don't know.
Never seen that sort of route before.
Good day.
You can do quests.
That's what we're doing right now, baby!
Wait, where am I?
Oh...
Took us...
Wait, over here.
Who is that?
Sh...
Shmear's house.
Shmear?
Is that another person?
Oh, here we go.
Um...
No time to talk.
Okay, we can't talk to you, Glarther.
Oh, yes!
That's right!
There was one he...
Like...
Uh...
Here?
Bernadette?
Is one person?
And then, who are you?
Good morning.
Daveed!
Yeah!
Have you tried to get a job?
A blibber burger?
My talents would be wasted flipping burgers.
Is this his house?
Yes!
Daveed had the brother!
Daveed had the brother.
I'm not talking to you.
Oh, wait.
Shmear.
Am I supposed to kill you?
No.
Supposed to kill Bernadette...
And Daveed...
And...
Tutius Sextius.
Why do the guards have such good hearing?
I remember Daveed being hard too, because what am I supposed to do about his brother?
How do people do this quest?
How?
Accept the bounty consequences in jail.
After everyone is dead, chaos must flow.
Waiting till they're asleep, yeah.
geek.
What?
Papa.
Papa Shamir.
I... I think what I was hoping, though, is that... Or rather... Okay, hold on.
Don't the characters level... Up with you?
You know?
So, if I... Get stronger, so do they.
Some of them.
NPCs don't.
Not town NPCs, generally.
Oh.
The spawned mob still.
So, maybe... Maybe I come back at, like, level 10.
I'm 7.
20 as sexy as level cap is 17!
Okay.
Let's see... Let's see how beefy they are.
Let's do, like, 15 hours.
14 hours.
E-Tina just standing in the streets.
She's dummy thick.
No!
Can freely take novice alchemy gear.
Sell back to them for a sharp knife.
Heiko had a pretty good knife, though.
Oh, wait.
It's only 10pm.
That's just now.
Oh.
Look at him!
Come...
Fuck!
Let's do, like, five hours.
Let's try.
I just wanna try!
Worth using that fancy melee weapon in some dungeons?
Yeah, I just think it's so fun to kill.
What are you doing?
Can you spare a coin?
No.
I have to kill this lady.
Can you get out of here?
Thank you.
Nobody around?
Okay.
I got it, baby.
I also need...
Oh, whoops.
Well, this is fine.
Let's change...
Let's change to...
Back to this.
I don't know.
My bow is way stronger, though.
Drain strength.
Damage health on strength.
Oh, wait.
10 points.
Okay, I'll try it.
And then we'll also...
Do the poison.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let me quick save.
Potion of illness.
Because even if I can just kill one...
That'll be nicer for the rest.
You know?
Is that her?
Yes.
I tried charging, you guys.
You saw what happened.
It didn't charge at all.
Oh, it did?
Okay.
I don't believe you.
By the gods, there's a psychopath on the loose!
You
think they'll know it's me?
Oh, this is not...
There's no window.
I need to start planning my escape routes, you know?
So far, so good?
Good morning!
So far, so good!
Oh...
Oh!
Oh my god!
We did it!
Good job, team!
We got away with it.
Okay, I'm safe.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I'm on that murder high.
See?
Oh, wait.
This is not Tutius' house.
Tutius...
Let's see how close he's got, like, some...
Wait.
Who's over here?
Let's see how close the guards are to his house, you know?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's just a fire.
One moment, sir.
Oh, here, here, here, here.
There's that guy.
I think it's this guy that gets me every time.
I think.
This is the guy that, like...
What is it now?
That, like, hears him scream.
Hmm.
And then...
We have some patrollers.
What time was it?
5.30.
And then for...
The brothers...
Where were they?
Wait, why don't they show up?
Eh?
Heh heh.
Huh?
Casually ignores the police to help starving children.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Here, here, here.
Here.
And there's also a guard parked right there.
No.
Tricky.
They make it tricky, huh?
Whose house is this?
Oh, the Two Sisters Lodge.
Two of them.
Markinus, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Can you wait it out inside the house after killing it?
Well, the guards come in.
You know?
Hmm.
Let's get...
Stronger and we'll come back.
We've killed one.
We've killed a woman.
What?
Larther, are you proud of me?
Can't you see that I'm very busy?
I told you not to speak to me in public.
We'll meet tonight at the place we discussed.
Not tonight.
Ah, sorry.
I have no idea what time it is.
Tootieus is probably the hardest.
I don't know.
Depending...
The brothers might be really hard too, because...
Because...
I think I have to kill them both?
I don't know.
And then...
I have to make more poison.
I have to get more poison.
Severing.
Oh, Magicka.
No, I know it's only one brother that I have to kill.
But I feel like I have to give both of them so that they both shut up.
I think the brothers might be the hardest.
Anyway.
Let's, um...
We'll save the other two for later, once I'm stronger.
What should we do now?
How much gold do I have?
2,396.
Not bad.
What did we need?
Like, 5,000?
It's like a crazy amount.
This one.
Where spirits have least.
Should we go find a cave?
5k for the house.
No rest for the wicked.
Oh, yeah.
If we...
We can also do the...
Do our brothers and sisters.
We can do that with a killing.
Killing.
Oh, yeah.
This is the main quest.
I forgot about that.
If you off every single person thing in the game, it would technically resolve all storylines and be...
I know.
Join the mages guild.
Did I not do that?
Let's go...
Uh, what was it?
Let's go back to...
To Vampire Man.
And go accept the quest.
Yeah.
Yes.
What main quest?
Oh, hello.
Good morning.
Oh, hi-yo.
Gozaimasu.
Ah, how great.
How do you do?
I look left.
I look right.
Nobody watch me go into the abandoned house.
Walk the dark path of the brotherhood.
I am.
It's actually so spooky in here.
End of the world can wait for real estate.
I want to get my house and then we can...
Then we can...
Continue the main story.
I don't know how long today's stream will be.
Really just depends on how I feel.
I'm kind of hot, though.
I turn on my fan.
Hello, Skelly.
Hello.
Hello, everybody.
Skelly.
So good to see you.
Is there anything you need?
No.
Um...
Now I know that guy has hair.
So...
I'll recognize him.
Is he in here?
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's Oceeva.
That's right.
I miss bald Vincent.
Me too.
I'm so...
Sad.
That they patched his hair.
Why would they do that?
At least we got it, you know?
At least we got to see it.
Whoa.
Well, everybody's asleep.
Oh, this guy's a jerk.
It is an honor to make your acquaintance.
The little brow is clean in his face.
Take a nap and level up.
I don't have a level up.
It appears as like a little icon.
Maybe he's in his room.
Maybe he's asleep too.
Are you not an early riser?
Cute, right?
Yeah, he's so cute.
I love that this place has pets.
Oh, there you are.
He looks so bad with his hair.
Back for more?
Yes.
It just so happens I have another contract available.
One that requires an expert in infiltration.
Does he know?
Of course, I will gladly accept.
As always, you fail to disappoint me.
Your target is a dark elf named Valen Dreath.
He thinks he's safe in prison.
He is tragically mistaken.
You fail to disappoint you.
A prisoner recently escaped from the prison using a set of secret tunnels connected to the Imperial City's sewer system.
It's a perfect way inside.
There's a mod that makes it permanent evolve.
Just outside the Imperial prison is a grating that leads to the sewers.
It has recently been tightly locked, but I will provide a key.
It should be easy enough to locate Dreath in his small cell.
Besides, I think you know the way, hmm?
Valen Dreath has been imprisoned for many years.
His tongue is sharp, but his body is limp and frail.
He will prove an easy, pleasurable kill.
You will receive a bonus if you fulfill the contract without killing any of the prison guards.
Now go.
And may the Night Mother go with you.
No rest for the wicked completed.
Okay, now scheduled for execution.
One Imperial City sewers...
Oh, nice!
I'm still not over it.
You fail to disappoint...
Why would you say...
It's like...
It sounds like a double negative.
Or it is a double...
Wait.
It sounds...
It sounds like I'm failing and disappointing you.
It's confusing.
Alright, where are we going?
Imperial Prison Sewer.
Oh, that's right!
That's where I came out of.
You cannot fast travel...
Oh, from this location.
Okay.
Mean token first.
Yeah.
He just should have...
Maybe thought of a better way to say it.
Okay, so we can't kill the guards.
But are there rat people...
In the sewers again?
And can I kill those?
You are a failure at disappointing us.
I don't fail at nothing.
I'll disappoint you.
Yeah, there were rat people in the sewers.
He's trying to distract from the wig.
Bizarre word humor.
Like, we all know...
What are those?
What are those crawling around?
Did you guys see that?
Okay, there's an imp over there.
What was that thing crawling?
Oh, those are the crabs?
They looked huge.
Let's, um...
Put our...
Which one was it?
What...
Which one did I use?
The steel bow?
Maybe...
Or the iron bow?
They both have the same damage.
I guess either one is fine.
Wait, but iron it...
A steel arrow...
Oh, I guess it's fine.
Either is fine.
Yeah.
I forgot to ask...
Oh my gosh.
It's so late to ask this.
But is the volume okay?
Are the graphics looking alright?
Feel free to speak up.
E.T.
looking at it.
Yeah, our name is E.T.
now.
Everything good?
Oh, what is that?
Green stained cup.
Okay, let's go in.
Oh, see, there's rats in there.
And let me know too.
Oh, I have entered the sewers beneath the Imperial Prison.
Now I must proceed through the sewers into the prison itself and kill Val and Dread.
This is kind of a long trek back, no?
This is a long quest.
I better get a lot of money for this.
But, um...
What was I going to say?
I don't remember.
Where's the other rat at?
Oh, there he is.
It's like right behind him.
Can I get him?
Yes, I can.
Ha ha ha.
Will there be guards and stuff patrolling now?
I wonder.
Oh.
Uh.
Ha ha ha.
The gate is sealed.
We'll activate it.
We have...
...reached an impasse.
Nitro, thank you so much!
Fine iron is as powerful as steel, but lighter.
Fine steel is as powerful as silver, but lighter.
Oh, wait!
I don't know the way, you guys!
I don't know at all!
What is that?
A spider?
What is that thing?
Mr. Krabs?
Oh, it is a crab!
Mud crab.
These things are...
Why are you holding gold?
Crab meat sounds delicious.
Luckily, Itina doesn't need to eat.
I hear something.
I don't know the way at all, you guys.
What is that sound?
Oh!
Something's in the water.
There's...
Oh, the red arrow.
Oh my gosh, you're right!
I didn't even notice it.
Those are some crazy fish!
Oh, those are the slaughter fish!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm just gonna go.
I hear something walking.
I wanna be sneaky, though.
Okay, I don't think there's any...
Oh!
Arrow ready?
Is it small?
Is it big?
What could it be?
I don't hear it no more.
Heh heh heh.
Got his butt.
Lock pick!
We'll take potions.
I don't need torch.
No!
Not...
Not lick!
Lock!
I should do, like, some vocal exercises before I play this game.
We're like, lock!
Pick!
Lock!
I don't know why I say lick-pock.
I don't know.
My brain works in mysterious ways, everybody.
Did I get my arrows?
I think so, yeah.
So we go this way.
Just making sure.
There's got...
Oh, there's a mudcrub.
I feel like there's gotta be other stuff in here.
Even chests.
Nothing.
Malilu-lay.
Lock pick.
Who?
Where?
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
Oh, here he comes.
Sneak!
I did?
What?
Freud would suggest you secretly want to lick pockets.
I don't!
I never have!
Oh, do I need to go down here?
Wait.
Shows like this direction.
I guess down there.
Yeah, I think I do.
Likely story.
Sometimes, you know, when you pick up pennies.
And they...
And then you're...
And that...
And then you...
And then your hand smells brassy.
That happens sometimes with my jewelry.
I get like really cheap jewelry.
That's how I imagined.
It probably would taste like...
Licking blood or something.
Oh, oh, gosh.
The music scared me for a second.
Trying to see if I see anything.
I don't think I do.
Don't lick coins.
I don't!
I hear the rats, but I don't see them.
That's fine.
She's cool.
Oh!
Don't bother me, crab.
I'm mostly afraid of guards spotting me.
I'm gonna save real quick.
So that...
Just in case we do get spotted.
What the...
What am I hearing?
Mysterious?
So sneaky.
We are stealth.
We are so sneaky.
What am I hearing?
Oh,
maybe it's that guy.
So many crabs.
Where were all you guys before?
Where were all these crabs when I was traversing the first time?
Sewer sounds.
Maybe that's it.
Okay.
Onwards?
At the crab rave.
I don't remember this part at all.
One time damage.
They're not as aggressive as I thought they'd be.
Sometimes.
I feel like sometimes they really just come at you, you know?
Oh, well...
I spoke...
Way too soon.
Yep, exactly as I said.
Yep, just like that.
What?
They look cute?
To me, they look delicious.
Wait, does this open up?
The gate is open remotely.
But also, I need to go that way.
Like this direction.
Open remotely.
You guys see it?
Oh!
I see it!
We have gained access!
Yes!
No elp.
I don't need your elp.
Do these go anywhere?
No.
What's to be in here?
29 gold!
I'll take it.
Okay.
Very nice.
I'm as lost as you, boss.
We'll figure it out.
Easy peasy.
We're safe scumming a little bit.
It's okay.
Nothing here?
Nothing here.
Door to sewers.
Oh!
Whoa!
Why are they so dumb?
Wait!
Was this the area?
No.
I don't...
Where?
I don't remember these areas at all.
Ah!
And...
Go!
We got him.
We'll get this guy too.
This guys.
And...
Shoot!
Oh!
No, he's dead.
I'll take my arrow back.
Thank you very much.
And my other arrow back.
I'm a master fisher.
The slaughter fish has become the slaughtered.
Easy as shootin' fish.
Curious that the part of the game she locked into the most was unlocking things.
Yeah.
I'm afraid of people down here.
I'm afraid of the humans.
I don't care about all the fish and the rats and the crabs.
Is that a crab?
No, that's not a crab.
I'm afraid of some guard being like...
What are you doing down here?
Who?
Crab.
Oh, I have to go that way.
Hold on, I'm exploring a little bit first.
Cheese wheel.
The rats must be...
That's why they're partying.
Nice.
Wait, there's another thing we can go through.
Gate.
Cheese to meet you.
Stop.
You violated the sewer.
Is it a crime to be...
Going around in a sewer anyway?
I don't think so.
Well, my sneak has increased.
Let's go.
That's always a good thing.
Become sneakier.
Okay, now where am I going?
I've...
I've strayed from the path a little bit.
The gate is sealed.
I don't know.
What was the point?
Huh.
Go to the...
Oh.
That crab scared me.
Lucky.
To the right.
To the right, right, right, right, right.
Look at that gate.
Where's the other one?
I know there's two of you in here.
Oh.
God, they're so chunky.
They look like my cat.
The point was the 29 gold we made along the way.
We'll be making gold.
Once we...
Kill the guy.
Eye on the prize, everybody.
We're gonna kill that guy.
Who's in jail.
And then...
Oh.
I think we found the exit.
Wait, we didn't go through the...
Why is there...
We didn't go through...
The caves.
This is way less...
Of a trek than I remember.
Ha ha ha ha.
Of course I'm proud to do my duty.
But it's a waste of time.
What are we guarding?
Cold stone and shadow.
That's it.
I'm not disagreeing with you, believe me.
Those assassins got what they wanted.
The emperor is dead.
They got no reason to come back.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
But will the captain listen?
No.
We must have a presence.
The prison must remain secure.
Yeah, what a laugh, huh?
Cold stone.
I love cold stone.
Just who are we keeping secure?
Dreath?
Since that other one got away, he's the only one rotting down here.
Yeah, well, I guess you can't blame Captain Montrose too much.
That's the guy we have to kill.
This is his big career move, after all.
Got to impress that lot upstairs.
Yeah, true enough.
Oh, well.
I best be getting back...
Okay, I'm just trying to...
Don't forget.
We're meeting for drinks later at the bloated float.
Ew.
Oh, I'll be there.
How could I miss a chance to see you cower before that big orc bouncer?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I ain't afraid of no one.
Courage is my middle name.
I...
Oh, never mind.
Bloated float is a terrible name.
Okay, so he leaves.
And is this guy, like, facing away?
I did...
I did save right before we came up here.
So we can experiment a little bit.
Where was he...
Where was the person he was talking to?
That's what I wonder.
We'll get an extra bonus if we don't kill any guards, but...
You know, if we have to, we have to.
Oh, golly.
Um...
Is there a way to get up?
No.
Uh-oh.
I run?
I'm running?
Which way?
Where do I go?
This way?
A little dead end?
Oh.
Where'd the arrow go?
Arrow's gone.
Oh, here it is.
Run.
Where'd the arrow go?
Arrow?
Wait, this is where I came from.
The game bamboozled me.
Ouch.
Wait.
Which way do I go?
The game bamboozled me.
This way.
Nope.
Where?
Can they see me?
Oh.
Use it again.
Ouch.
Yeah, I'm...
Oh.
That guy likes me.
I'm gonna die.
I'm just trying to figure out where to go.
Where do I go?
Oh my god.
How are you guys so fast?
Okay, so there's four.
Guys, I'm so lost.
It tells me to go...
I went the wrong way.
My help if you...
Open your map.
I'm getting chased for my life.
I don't have...
Oh my god, they're here.
Oh.
Bye-bye.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I fought Minecraft more fearsome than you.
Okay, here.
Oh.
Leave me alone.
And then...
Okay, fine.
I'll open my map.
What the hell?
This doesn't help at all.
How am I supposed to read this?
What?
I'm not my help if you open your map, Mito.
Yeah.
Absolute gibberish.
Okay, hold on.
Ugh.
Like, how am I supposed to get up here?
Apparently, I was here.
And then I...
I messed it up.
How did I mess it up?
Typical Mito.
Okay, where am I?
Okay, maybe...
Right here.
Ah, ah, ah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah.
We're doing it?
Wait, I went the wrong way.
Don't come after me.
Oh.
I'm lost.
This is so mean.
Dead end!
Oh my god, I'm at one HP in a dream.
Where'd the arrow go?
Oh.
Eh?
Use a potion?
So true.
Inventory.
Potion of healing.
Nice.
In fact, I'll just do two.
Okay.
Back to the map.
I need to turn a rat...
Wait, I need to come back from where I came.
Uh-oh.
But it looks like a dead end.
There must have...
Oh, it must have been the other side.
Okay.
I'll have to loop them maybe.
If I could even do that.
Oh, I can.
Let's go.
Let's...
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Oh, wait, wait.
Am I at the right place?
Yes.
Um...
Is this an exit?
The bastion.
But they're gonna be chasing me forever, aren't they?
They're gonna be chasing me forever out of here.
I think I gotta reload.
But now I know...
Ish.
Where'd it go?
But how do I get around this guy?
Oh, geez.
Oh.
Why does your character look like a female ET?
Her name is E-Tina.
Of course I'm proud to do my duty.
Important spell effect to help with sneaking is detect life so you can see people through walls and not accidentally turn a corner into guards.
Oh.
But it's a waste of time.
What are we guarding?
I'm not disagreeing.
Oh, there is a guy here.
Um.
I see.
I'm not disagreeing with you.
Believe me.
Those assassins got what they wanted.
I don't think my sneak is high enough.
They got no reason to come back.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
But will the captain listen?
No.
We must have a presence.
The prison must remain secure.
Yeah, what a laugh, huh?
Just who are we keeping secure?
Do detect life.
Since that- I don't even know if I know that.
Let's see.
Um.
I don't even know if I know that.
I don't know how to do magic in this game.
Yeah.
I guess you can't blame Captain Montrose too much.
This is his big career move after all.
Got to impress that lot upstairs.
Yeah, true enough.
Oh well, I best be getting back to my watch.
Potion or Spell of Invisibility.
I definitely don't think I have that.
Oh, I'll be there.
How could I miss a chance to see you cower before that big- Chameleon?
Oh, I do have that!
How long- Oh, it only lasts 30 seconds though.
It doesn't last long.
I'm trying to think.
Shadow shape, what's that?
Oh!
Invisibility on self!
For 30 seconds.
I think this one was only 25% too.
This one seems full.
I didn't even know I had invisibility.
Wilbur said, check if you have it.
And I said no.
I was a liar.
Here.
Um...
It runs out when you interact with doors.
So if I were to interact...
And kill the...
Guy?
Like if I open up his cell?
I think it would be best to use it on the way out then, no?
Open it up.
Would they still see me if I use it?
And I try to...
Like they see me.
I kill the guy.
I use it.
And I...
Leave.
You can just run on the way out.
But they'll chase me forever!
No!
You don't need it on the way out?
Only if they see you on the way in.
Oh, okay.
What sucks is...
My map is not filled out...
Anymore.
Because I had to restart.
Okay.
I think it was like...
Up and around.
Was this...
This was the first door.
And then it led to the second door.
Yes, yeah.
I think I remember.
Uh...
Okay, let's just...
We have to...
Wait it out anyway.
I think.
Unless...
Do you think I could get there in 30 seconds?
That's a pretty long time.
You know what?
Let's just try it.
Let's see how long it takes for us to get there.
Cuz...
I could try.
30 seconds is...
If I know where to go...
Oh wait!
The door!
That's right!
If I interact...
With any door?
Really?
Oh...
Get past the first door first.
Okay.
Yeah...
That's right...
Interact with anything.
Oh...
Okay.
How do I...
Also, how do I cast it?
So if I...
Have it equipped now...
If I press C...
Will it work?
Yes?
Okay.
Thank you!
Oh!
They're done.
I'm afraid of getting past this guy.
I don't know where the other guy goes.
Oh, he must go down like a further...
Do I need to go that way?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Huh.
Curious.
How do I get around this guy?
Maybe he turns around and goes...
Somewhere else.
Actually, is he down this way?
Okay.
First room done.
Now I don't know where the guys are gonna be at though.
Oh...
Ha ha ha ha!
Let's save.
Since we got through the first room.
I'm abusing the camera.
Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear.
Is that a chest?
I think anyone will hear.
I don't see anybody.
But I imagine it...
Okay, hold on.
This one...
This one was tricky.
Because I remember...
This is the one where I think I go down through here...
And then there's the two doors.
If I remember correctly.
Stick to edges and dark areas.
Okay.
Well then this...
This way would be better.
I save, so if...
We get caught, it's...
Not the end of the world.
I'm just a little baby.
I'm scared.
Was it here?
No.
Where does this go?
Needs a key.
I almost want to save, but I'm too scared to.
Plus what if it saves me in a pretty bad spot, you know?
Ah, sorry.
Um...
Map.
That's what I was doing.
Uh...
Then we go up here and then go around.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Could you do a not quick save?
Um...
I guess.
Oh yeah, I go...
Oh, it's different than what I remember.
This is the one...
Eh?
I can't remember.
Now I'm topsy-turvy.
Oh, this is where I looped them.
So I, uh...
I have a feeling someone's gonna come through here.
Yeah, yeah, we're almost there.
Okay, okay.
This is where I remember.
The map looks so...
Wonky that it's hard for...
Like, this is the one where I go around.
Yes, yes, yes.
It looks so wonky that I can't even...
Process.
I feel like someone's gonna walk through here, so I'm just gonna hide here.
Maybe not!
Okay.
Ugh...
I'm gonna save.
And there's nothing you can do about it.
Yeah, well...
What's it been?
Seven?
Eight years?
We've had a good long run, you and me.
I always knew it would end someday.
Eleven!
Eleven years in this rat-infested hole!
But I'm getting out!
Can I...
I guess I can leave through here.
I...
I assume that is the...
That's the goal.
Is to leave through...
That...
Eleven!
Oh yeah?
And where will you go, huh?
What will you do?
You can't survive out there.
Did I save?
You're an animal.
You belong in that cage.
I'm also watching out for these.
Don't worry.
Right.
I did?
Okay.
Save again.
Oh, and you'll become a king.
I'm scared.
Oh yeah!
Wait, this is my cell!
You'll see an imperial dog when I get out of here.
This is my cell!
And this is the guy that...
Wait, we're killing the guy that was rude to me at the beginning.
All right, all right.
I'm tempted to let you out right now if you'll just shut up.
I think I can get him through here.
Hey.
Yeah.
You're the one.
That day the emperor was killed.
Yeah, yeah.
They went through your cell.
You lucky strumpet.
But you came back?
Come on.
You've got to help me.
Let old Valen out of this cell.
You've got your freedom.
Now give me mine.
What do you say, huh?
Come on, friend.
Friend?
The night mother says goodbye.
You're going to die in here.
Say nothing.
Wow, we're so stoic and cool.
The night mother says goodbye.
What if I...
But then maybe he'll scream and alert the guards.
Yeah, we'll give you your freedom from your mortal coil.
Um...
We're going to say nothing.
We're going to be cool.
Now how do I kill you?
Um...
Do I have to open his cell?
Rip Bozo.
Yep.
How do I talk to him?
Wait.
I can't...
I can find a key nearby.
Oh, thank you.
And...
Yeah, maybe not the bow and arrow.
Let's change to...
The Sufferthorn.
And...
I will also do...
None of these really...
Oh, drain health!
Sufferthorn.
I don't think you can shoot through the bars.
I don't think so.
Okay.
You look like E.T.
Put some respect on her name.
Her name is E.T.
now.
Oh, here we go.
Wait.
Oh.
Here we go.
Valendreth is dead.
And no guards have been killed.
I must return to the sanctuary and speak to...
Vincent Valtieri to receive my reward as well as a bonus.
You got anything on you?
No.
Okay.
Yippee!
Oh, and peace.
Oh, wow.
It's so peaceful.
Hello.
Stop!
You violated the law.
Pay the court a fine or serve your sentence.
What do you mean?
Stolen goods now forfeit.
What did I do?
It's 40 gold.
Okay.
I'll pay it.
That's too bad.
I was hoping it would resist arrest.
How do you guys know what the price is?
Okay.
Here's the procedure.
We go to the castle.
First, we search you.
Confiscate any stolen goods.
Then you pay your fine.
I'll reload.
Oh, it says in the top left.
Oh, I...
I thought we were in the clear.
Okay.
I'm gonna reload.
And that guy just walks away, so it's fine.
I was like, hello.
Hello, Mr. Guard.
All right, all right.
I'm tempted to let you out right now if you'll just shut up.
Well, they, like, just didn't, you know, do anything before, so... I thought it was... I thought it was fun!
Like, I walked out, and they were like, ah, she's supposed to be here.
You know?
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I know you.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
The Night Mother says goodbye.
The Night Mother?
No, no!
Oh.
Wait, are they coming?
No one's coming to help you.
Okay.
Now I leave, and I don't talk to anybody.
What is it, citizen?
Yes, I'm a citizen!
Let's fast travel.
Home.
The guard asked for dreads...
For dreads what?
Assassination?
They just didn't want to deal with the guy anymore.
Clearly.
Woohoo!
How are you?
Oh, my God.
Oh, I thought you were naked for a second, mister.
Hello.
They'll never...
They'll never know.
They'll never know!
Oh.
I'm actually more surprised that that jail only had three...
Oh, well, technically four...
Jail cells.
That seems very small, no?
You showed off your stealth gaming skills.
Bravo, Minky.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Where is he?
Hello.
I won't bother your reading.
Well, they get mad now because I have the Imperial Jail Key.
Is that why they were mad at me?
Oh, wake up.
Give me my money.
So, you infiltrated the Imperial Prison, eliminated Vaylin Dress, and killed not one guard.
Hallway, oh.
Most excellent.
In addition to your standard reward, I present to you this bonus.
Behold, the scales of pitiless justice.
The scales of...
While carried, the scales will magically enhance your strength, intelligence, and agility.
But diminish your personality.
A powerful tool, indeed.
Oh.
The greatest soldier in the world!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
So, how much did I make from that?
Like, 200 gold?
100 gold.
That's it.
Minus two, Riz.
What is it?
Let's see.
What's this thing that we got?
What is it called?
Oh, the scales of pitiless justice.
I have to wear it?
I don't even need to use this shadow shape.
I'm too good, baby.
Oh, it's a pas...
Oh, you just carried it.
Okay, cool.
Let's put our bow back on.
I have to repair this soon.
Yeah.
It's pasive.
So, I...
Have a...
A poopy personality.
People want to be my friend.
Not only did you eliminate the target, but as six Imperial Legion escorts as well.
Most impressive.
So you heard.
Yes, yes, it was quite the debacle.
The head just wouldn't sever.
Cut.
Saw.
Hack.
I sit this.
I swear her tendons were made of steel.
Yes, well, if there's one thing you know how to do, it's...
Get yourself out of an unwinnable situation.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ah.
Well, I suppose I should get going.
So many contracts.
So little time.
Walk always in the shadow of Sithis.
Hey, Minky.
I can't wait to see you do silly stuff on off-kai this weekend.
Today's my birthday.
Can I get a Metal Gear?
Happy birthday.
Lucille, happy birthday!
I'm not singing birthdays at the moment, but I can say happy birthday to you!
Hold on.
Speaking of, let me...
Let me do my...
I have a spray.
For my throat.
So good to see you.
Is there anything you need?
She's so pretty.
Hello to my sister.
Is there something I can help you with?
My sister, oh sister.
Tell me about the rumors.
Don't tell anyone else, but someday I'm going to have Ochieva's position.
Just you wait and see.
Lucy and the Chance knows real talent when he sees it.
What if I want Ochieva's position?
Her hair is glitching out.
Uh-oh.
They brought back...
They brought back Vincent's hair to get rid of everybody else's.
The sacrifice must be made.
I think she...
I don't know if she would be able to pull off bald.
Antoinette...
Oh my god.
She's really...
She's glitching out of existence.
Someone must be bald.
It's like someone's...
Like flicking the...
Light switch on and off.
Oh Bethesda, you think you can stop the bald?
Nightmother.
I've always wondered who the Nightmother really is.
Some say she's an old woman who lives somewhere here in Cyrodiil.
But I'm not so sure.
Cyrodiil.
There must always be a bald one.
Sonata!
Oh my gosh.
It feels like forever since I've seen you.
Happy 14 months.
Thank you.
Oblivion is here...
For their hair.
Good luck, sister.
I hope you don't get killed.
I mean...
Um...
Well...
You know.
Why is she so awkward?
Let's see.
What do we want to do now?
Maybe we should go find a cave.
And...
Loot it.
You know, bald is the preferred hairstyle when everyone is trying to be bald.
True.
She seems nice.
Get another job from the vampire guy.
But they're so...
They're so...
I really wish I could kill these people.
Where is it?
It...
Par...
Paranoid.
This one.
I wish that we could do Glarthor's quest.
It pays so much.
Vampire gives you better weapons.
Oh, true.
How much?
It pays 1,000 gold.
The arena pays really well.
I'm not much of a fighter, though.
Let's go see it.
Let's go wake him up and get another quest.
I have a special contract that needs fulfillment.
In truth, I don't wish to offer it to any other family member.
I've come to rely on your abilities.
We're that good?
Oh.
Wait.
Vincent, your hair.
Will it?
Side quest is Stop Oblivion.
And the main quest is Kill Tootie is Sexiest.
So true!
We're usually called upon to take a life.
But not this time.
This contract requires us to stage the assassination of a marked man.
Are you ready?
Okay.
Yes.
You must go to the city of Coral and break into the house of Francois Mottier.
Inside, you will find Mottier waiting for you.
Okay.
Do not kill him.
You see, Francois Mottier is a marked man.
Francois Mottier.
He owes a considerable sum to the wrong kind of people.
Oopsie.
So they have sent an enforcer to kill him.
Whoa.
Here.
You will use this specially poisoned knife to stage Mottier's death in the enforcer's presence.
Mottier himself will provide more details.
Okay.
This is an unusual contract.
Mottier had to make a special arrangement with us before it was approved.
Oh.
I trust in your professionalism.
Francois Mottier.
Poison knife.
The blade has been coated with a rare poison called Langerwine.
Langerwine.
One drop in a normal human bloodstream will mimic the effects of death immediately.
Ah.
I have provided you with a vial of antidote, which will be used to revive Francois Mottier after you successfully stage his death.
You should also know that there's only enough Langerwine on the blade for this one contract.
Okay.
After Mottier is sliced, the knife will be useless.
What if the guy who contracted us is going to be like, I'll pay you even triple, quadruple, double if you slice and dice him.
If you ever cut off his arms and you cut off his legs and you cut off his tongue and you cut off his toes and you cut off his head.
And I'll pay you quadruple.
Panko!
Thank you so much for the redirect!
Thank you!
Like the fake death pill at MGS.
Yeah, exactly!
That's an orbital vagabond.
I don't know.
Scales of pitiless justice are invisible because they're equipped up the butt.
Oh.
Huh?
We're about to not go kill somebody.
All raiders coming in?
I just killed a man.
I got him in...
Actually, I've killed two people this stream.
We're killing it.
Marilyn, thank you so much for the five gifted!
Reminding me why I fell in love with the games.
Yeah.
Thank you for the five gifted!
Teacup and yon-yon.
Thank you for the gifted!
Do I go?
Thank you for the five gifted!
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
All right, let's go not kill a man.
Good seeing you!
Bye-bye!
Goodbye!
Go back to sleep!
Mwah!
Sweet dreams.
Little kisses.
Oh!
I always...
I always go out the wrong way.
So good to see you!
Is there any...
Resting good fries!
Thank you for the five gifted!
Nah, I would have given him a butter kiss if he were bald.
Can you wish my friend Joe a happy birthday?
Happy birthday, Joe!
Better not be Joe Mama.
So we need to go to Quarrel.
Here!
And we meet a Frenchman!
The French.
Oh, it's daytime now.
Only asking for a single coin.
What if there was...
Wait, wasn't there a guy who was called something the leech?
Okay, so it's...
Francois Mortieri's house.
What's going on with you?
This one?
Wow, this guy's got a fancy looking place.
If you're expecting me, why'd you lock the door?
Oh!
I never fail!
Phil, thank you so much for the tagging to take you!
Ooh, my lock...
Lock picking went out.
Hee hee.
Impossible.
Oh.
Well, um...
Hello.
You must be the one Lucy and Lachance told me about.
We're in an O loop.
I've been expecting you.
Oh, oh, oh.
We haven't got much time, I'm afraid.
I borrowed quite a bit of gold from some underworld types.
I, uh...
I missed a payment.
Now they don't even want the money.
They say I insulted them.
They've sent an enforcer to kill me.
Oh!
His name is Hides' Heart.
But he's on his way here now.
That's why I hired you.
So you can fake my death.
Hides' Heart.
Okay, um...
By scythus, spit it out, you worm!
I'll be mean to him.
Oh, sorry.
Please, I'm sorry.
See, when Hides' Heart gets here, I'll put on a little act.
Then you cut me with the knife and it looks like I die.
You must then flee from Coral, and Hides' Heart must not be killed.
Okay.
That way he can go back and tell his employers I'm dead.
If you wait a day, my body will be put on display in the Coral Chapel Undercroft.
You can come to me then and administer the antidote.
Got all that?
Good.
Oh, okay.
Hides' Heart will be here any moment.
Oh.
Get ready.
Oh, I do hope this works.
Oh.
Uh.
Okay.
I'm getting ready.
Um.
I use the Langerwine Blade.
I have it ready.
The lockpick failed so that you could correctly say lockpick.
It's a trade.
Hides' Heart.
Carebearer Assassin Extraordinaire.
Okay.
I'm here.
Motieri, I know you're in there.
No reaction.
My employers are mostly pleased.
I'm coming in, and you can beg for your life.
Not that we'll...
Motier, I am here to exact payment.
In blood.
You will...
Who is this?
Oh, no.
What am I to do?
An underworld enforcer and a dark brotherhood assassin.
Both here to kill poor Francois.
The dark brotherhood?
Oh, you have been a naughty boy, Motier, haven't you?
Stand aside, assassin.
Motier...
I did it.
I must now flee.
Oh, shoot.
Get me out of here.
The acting...
Could have been better.
I'm fleeing Coral.
They're not going after me, are they?
Now I wait a day.
What time is it?
Oh.
I have fled Coral, and Hyde's heart has not been killed.
I must now wait a day so Motier can be discovered and placed in the Coral Chapel Undercroft.
There I must find Motier and administer the antidote that will revive them.
Oh.
Dear.
Okay.
Let's save.
And we wait a day.
We just chill, I guess.
Let's wait 24 hours.
Yeah, let's just go inside and wait.
Maybe.
Ytina just stands there for a whole 24 hours.
Hopefully, no one bothers me.
I'm going to stand right here really menacingly.
Whoa.
Oh.
Wow, that really worked.
Yawn.
Good morning.
How's anyone?
Stop right there, criminal scum.
Nobody breaks the law on my watch.
I'm confiscating your stolen goods.
Now pay your fine, or it's off to jail.
How did he know?
It's only 40 gold.
That's like almost half of what I earned on my last mission.
I did save.
I'll just, I'll just, uh, reload.
That's too bad.
Okay.
Oh.
I'll just, uh, reload.
What am I in trouble for?
Is it the key?
How else was I supposed to get out?
I was all I wanted to ask him if it was before my body was discovered.
Jail is like eating a second home at this point.
What if I just ditched the key somewhere?
You should be able to pay off your bounty at the thieves' guild.
Yeah, we'll have to do that.
Your bounty is from the last stream.
Because you were caught trespassing.
No kidding?
No.
No way.
Wow, these deer also haven't moved in 24 hours.
Oh, there's an imp!
There's an imp!
Let's see if I can get him.
Wait.
Sniper attack!
Yippee!
Look at that.
Look at the...
What's it called?
There's like the trail whenever I do that.
Looks kind of funky.
Little Ken doll...
Looking buddy.
What are you doing here, anyway?
Causing mischief.
Okay.
The ghost thing.
It was in the knee?
How apt.
You can check your current bounties and your character stats.
Oh.
And no, if you have a bounty, it won't just go away by itself.
Every guard knows what you did forever.
Wait.
Character stats here?
Sneet!
I forgot that was our class.
Cure factions.
Wait.
How many locks have I picked?
44!
Which is it under?
It was near the top?
Bounty.
40.
What do you mean my infamy is 9?
My fame is only 5.
Item stole.
Wow.
Okay.
Don't talk to the guard.
Screw you.
Hello.
I don't think we've met.
Are you new in town?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ah, yes, I am.
Pleased to meet you.
Likewise.
I'm always glad to meet someone new.
Welcome.
I'm sure my mother would be glad to meet you as well.
Why is your mom going to meet me?
My mother owns northern goods and trade in Coral.
Okay.
Any rumors?
Have you seen Valis Odile recently?
Spends all day in the tavern since his boys left.
Oh.
Hope you're having a great weekend.
Thank you, Riot.
You too.
Be seeing you.
Bye-bye.
Oh, I gotta go to the chapel.
That's the mage's guild.
I gotta go to the chapel.
Look at the dog.
Have mercy.
Just one coin.
Look at...
I've never seen the dogs before.
They're so cute.
They're huge.
Don't look at me like that.
Nermous.
He looks so polite.
When he's standing there.
That's my cue.
Why does he look like that?
Why is he looking so polite?
Why is anybody saying anything or doing anything?
Okay.
Oh.
Bye.
Just a chill guy.
So, technically, I think I'm not allowed down here.
Isn't that the case?
Oh, wait.
I have to go to the undercroft.
Right.
Wait.
What was the quest?
Oh, gosh.
I pressed Q.
For quest.
Let me just...
Quest.
Yes, it was the undercroft.
Okay.
This one is better.
Aren't there skellies down here?
It starts with a hundred disposition towards everyone.
Since she's such a good being.
Aww.
Where's our guy?
Oh, he's close.
There he is.
Oh.
I can take his stuff.
I have administered the Langerwine antidote.
And Francois Mortier has awakened from his poison-induced sleep.
I should now speak with him and make sure he's well enough to travel to the Grey Mare.
I don't think he would have anything in his pockets anyway.
Hello?
Wake up.
Oh.
I'm a bit stiff, but quite fine otherwise.
He did not look dead.
He literally was moving.
My family members are buried here, you know.
Which leads me to something I may have failed to mention before.
My ancestors will see my revival as a desecration of their tomb.
This undercroft is...
Well, quite cursed.
Huh?
Any desecration will cause my ancestors to rise from their graves and defend their resting place.
I can hear them coming as we speak.
What?
You must protect me.
Escort me to the Grey Mare where I can buy passage out of coral.
Uh, what?
Here they come.
What?
Oh my, Aunt Margaret.
You're looking the worst for where?
No way.
Where?
Oh my god, there's zombies.
Oh my god.
Sir, this is something you really should have mentioned beforehand, I fear.
Excuse me?
Oh, don't just go running at them.
Oh my god.
Did he just do a spin?
Sir, I can take the mort flesh.
The flying back kick.
Okay, Francois.
Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't do it.
Don't do it, don't do it.
Don't run!
Okay, good.
Oh, stop it.
I forgot to mention that now my ancestors are angry at me.
I have desecrated their grave.
Uh, was it this way?
I think so.
Come on, come on.
I can't believe this.
I, I can't believe this is happening.
That is, you will be quiet about the dead man walking.
That is kind of awkward.
Don't mind the zombies downstairs.
Okay, where do I take you?
No, it's safe.
Follow me.
Imagine if he tried to rush and punch cars.
Where am I taking you?
Oh, let's go this way.
Let's follow the red arrow.
This is right under a church.
You'd think a priest would have exorcised the place.
I know.
I'm a little confused.
Wait, so every time I would go to the, to the thieves' guild and be, it would say...
Oh, in here.
Where'd he go?
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
Where were you?
And it said, get rid of my bounty?
I could have done that.
Ah, the Grey Mare.
Coral's finest repository of wine, women, and song.
I haven't time for fools.
Be seeing ya.
Okay, you walked up to her.
What am I supposed to do here?
Ah, the Grey Mare.
From here, I will be able to arrange for transportation out of Cyrodiil.
You have served me well, Assassin.
You're welcome.
Francois is forever in your debt.
Farewell.
Why did we help this guy?
How much money did he...
Thanks again, Assassin.
Your services have been invaluable.
Soon I will find passage...
Okay.
Paul?
Bye.
But, like...
How much money did he pay...
To the...
Dark Brotherhood, you know?
To...
Get this kind of service.
Like a non-kill.
Unless...
We just didn't like the moneylenders...
And we were trying to spite them.
You know?
I don't know you, and I don't care to know you.
You do know me, actually.
But, yeah.
Keep pretending like you don't...
You don't know me.
I have no bounty.
I don't know you, and I don't care to know you.
I'm gonna start saying that to people on...
Oh, on the streets.
You know how, like...
Have...
Actually, I'm gonna look this up afterwards.
I don't...
I wonder if...
If...
I feel like this is the perfect game...
For, like, Mega64 to...
To do, you know?
Like, have them do their little skits.
Where they just...
Someone walks by, and they just say something.
I don't know if they've ever done one before.
Of the skim.
Oh, cheeva.
Where's our bald man?
They did a Skyrim.
Ah, okay.
Oh, I did see Joel Haver's Oblivion video.
I did, I did.
That was pretty funny, too.
Oh.
Ah, so Mottieri has escaped.
Well done.
I've reached Eliminator rank.
As payment, I am pleased to award you this amulet.
Cruelty's heart.
As well as another advancement in rank.
Nice.
I hereby bestow upon you the title of Eliminator.
Wow.
Your blood is cold.
Your heart, hard.
You exemplify everything the Dark Brotherhood stands for.
I present to you now this key.
It unlocks the well behind the abandoned house above.
Ah, nice.
Thank you.
Use it to gain hidden, quick access to this sanctuary.
Thank you, finally.
Goodness gracious.
Oh.
So I got what else?
What else did you give me?
Some kind of heart?
The necklace.
What would it be under?
Oh, here it is.
Cruelty's heart.
Fortify willpower on self.
Fortify strength on self.
Wait, it looks so good.
Target wasn't eliminated.
I now bestow upon you the title of Eliminator.
We're just that good at doing our job.
Um, the quest was eliminated.
Excuse me, sister.
Can you spare a moment?
Yes, brother.
Is it true what I've heard about your most recent contract?
You were forced to eliminate everyone?
Even the non-essentials?
Oh.
You must mean the orphanage contract.
The orphanage contract.
Well, it's true.
The children actually tried to defend themselves.
Poor dears.
Yes, well, if there's one thing you know how to do, it's get yourself out of an unwinnable situation.
Oh, well, I'd love to continue chatting, but I have to prepare for my next contract.
You know, that mages guild matter.
You understand.
Sithis be with you, sister.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Um, I think...
Oh.
Gift from the night mother herself.
Please, tell me how I can help.
She's getting right in between the arm.
Oh, my God.
This is attempted murder.
I love how they just really try to make this dark, um, brotherhood, like, as...
as evil as possible.
They're just like, oh, yes.
From the night mother herself.
Please.
Well, now, you are an ambitious one, aren't you?
Yeah.
I'm afraid I have no more contracts for you.
Our time working together has come to an end.
Instead, you must report to Ochiever here in the sanctuary.
She will be providing all your contracts from now on and is waiting for you as we speak.
Oh, okay.
Before you go, however, I intend to make good on an offer I made some time ago.
As a vampire, I may pass my gift on to others as I see fit.
You have served me well.
And I choose now to extend that gift to you.
Shall I use my dark powers and turn you into a vampire?
Wait.
It sucks?
Wait, why?
It's not worth?
It's not good?
What?
It kind of sucks in this game.
It's the worst?
You take damage from the sun.
Oh, yeah.
I'll think about it.
Not right now.
Thank you.
Yes, I can understand your trepidation.
For it is not every day one is invited to join the ranks of the undead, eh?
If you ever change your mind, fear not.
My offer will always be open.
Simply return and speak to me about the dark gift, and we can proceed.
Because, like, what if I go to those people that I need to kill for Glarthor, and I just...
You know?
And then...
They can't even scream.
Eat you now!
Where the hell you been, loca?
Already undead.
Thanks now.
I was gonna say, though, about this...
Goodbye.
This guild.
They're just so funny.
They'll be like, Oh, that contract you had...
About killing the poor puppies that were gifted to the...
To the...
To the sick, bedridden children.
How did that go?
And they're like, Yes, I murdered every puppy and every child.
They're like...
They're like, This is the evil guild, and we'd spare no one.
It's so funny.
It's, like, comical how...
How evil they are.
Oh, Tiva!
Ah, greetings.
I have been waiting for you.
As Vicente surely told you...
Oh, his name is Vicente.
Sorry, I've been calling him Vincent.
Tim has come to an end.
From now on, you will receive all assignments directly from me.
In fact, your next contract is available now.
Oh, gosh.
Ever since I got my new chair, it's awesome for stretching my back.
Contract.
Um, contract.
In the Imperial City, there lives a High Elf who must be removed from existence.
Finding this person may prove challenging.
Are you interested?
Always.
I accept the contract.
I knew you wouldn't be able to resist.
Your target is a High Elf named Falien.
He lives somewhere in the Imperial City and fancies long walks.
Oh.
Unfortunately, that's all we know.
We don't know which district he calls home, which establishments he frequents, or anything about his schedule.
Okay.
This contract will require a bit of detective work.
I suggest you speak to your fellow brothers and sisters and see if they can offer any advice.
High Elf.
Ah, yes.
There is one more thing.
Yeah?
The Imperial City is also home to an Imperial Legion captain named Adamus Philida.
Do you know who that is?
Uh...
Philida!
That self-righteous lapdog!
Actually, I don't think I've ever heard of this guy.
Have I?
He's the one from the docks.
I don't know.
Philida has dedicated his life to eradicating the Dark Brotherhood.
And he becomes rather irate when our duties take us to the Imperial City.
I see.
When that happens, he tends to make our lives uncomfortable.
Let's not give the good captain any reason to go poking around in our affairs, hmm?
Okay.
If possible, do away with Feli in some place out of the way.
Definitely indoors with no other people around.
Okay.
A secure location with no witnesses.
This will make it look like a simple murder.
Philida will be none the wiser and you'll receive a nice bonus.
Now go, and may Sithis go with you.
Hearing the phrase detective work in a fantasy setting is odd.
I know.
I feel like they're going to give me a...
Like a long coat and a...
And a...
A top...
Not top hat.
A fedora or something.
Man, I love mean Tony socks.
Thank you.
Thank you for 15 months.
And now we can use this.
All right.
Let's go find Phelan.
We're Phelan.
Oh, no, no.
We ain't failing this jab.
Oh, I think we need to go...
Oh, wait.
They said to talk to our brothers and sisters.
Just kidding.
Brothers.
That was not minus two.
Fedora Minto is on my wish list.
But, of course, what troubles you?
Everyone's talking about your latest exploits.
I know what you're thinking.
Go, Gron.
He's too big to be sneaky.
Well, you're right.
Me?
I like to just go in and hack my targets to pieces.
Ha ha.
Um.
Contract.
Now, this is what I'm talking about.
You kill them up close.
Face to face.
And you still get the bonus.
I wish all the contracts were like that.
That's not helpful at all.
Happy hunting, my sister.
Not only did you eliminate the target, but...
Oh.
You...
Ah, dear friend.
Sorry, I don't mean the button, but...
May I steal a moment of your time?
I have a rather delicate situation I was hoping you could help me with.
Big surprise hydration check.
I've been drinking!
This is a personal matter.
And will have no bearing on your standing within the Dark Brotherhood.
Would you like to hear more?
Wait, what's this?
Uh, yes?
I find your decision most agreeable.
Now, the details.
Far south of here, on the southern end of Cyrodiil, lies a swamp called Bogwater.
You're giving me a job?
Called Bogwater.
Bogwater.
Hiding in that swamp, you will find an Argonian shadow scale named Scartail.
Kill this renegade and bring me his heart as proof of the deed.
Why?
What do I get out of this?
I do so love pursuing a contract in the Imperial City.
The alleys, the shadows, the challenge of evading for this Legion troops.
You can ask why?
Okay.
I envy you.
You want this?
Scartail, there it is.
When Ocheva and I train with the Dark Brotherhood as children, we befriended another initiate, a shadow scale by the name of Scartail.
The three of us were inseparable.
When our training was completed, we reluctantly parted ways.
But now, now, the unthinkable has happened.
What happened?
Scartail has fled Black Marsh and refuses to fulfill his duties as royal assassin.
This is an act of treason.
This treachery must be punished.
Just as a member of the Dark Brotherhood cannot kill a fellow family member.
A shadow scale is forbidden from slaying another shadow scale.
That is why you must go to Bogwater and eliminate that treacherous snake.
Please, kill Scartail.
So Ocheva and I can put this matter behind us.
I see.
May you walk always in the shadow of Sixth, dear sister.
Thank you.
Tell me how I can help.
Shut up.
Why is everybody talking to me at once?
Nobody is telling me any actual helpful information about my quest.
What?
What are you doing over here?
I didn't know the skelly walked this far.
What are you going into the bedroom for?
I am honored by your presence.
Bye.
How can Ocheva be of assistance?
He's sleepy.
It's time to switch out.
This guy's...
Oh, wait.
Get away from me.
Yeah, this guy's the jerk.
You again?
I thought I'd made it clear.
I am not looking for...
Oh, wait.
He doesn't give...
He doesn't give help.
Foul-smelling ape.
You're mean.
His rickety bones.
It fills my heart with warmth.
So mean.
Okay.
I'm gonna wake you up.
Oh, she's gotta come all the way over here.
Hello, dear sister.
Is there something I can help you with?
This is jump scare.
Know what I'd do?
Talk to Falien.
Learn who he is.
Maybe then you can lead him to a secluded place.
Then, when you're alone...
You know.
Oh, there's some actual good advice.
Good luck, sister.
I hope you don't get killed.
I mean...
A little red...
Well...
Schemer.
So we gotta seduce Falien.
I think E-Tina...
Wait.
We have the scales that make our personality ass.
What are you doing?
Are you...
It fills my heart with warmth to see you again.
Excuse me.
I'm trying to leave.
Okay.
We're gonna be...
So...
Cute.
Let's go find this guy.
I guess we go here.
Falien.
Hat-duck.
Wait.
What time is it?
Also, since we're at the Imperial City...
We can get our bounty...
Taken away.
Wait.
It's...
The waterfront, right?
What time is it, though?
I think it's too early.
Let's go to the waterfront.
It might...
I rather...
I think it's...
Too late.
I think...
He might have...
Gone home.
We could try.
I also wanna go kill that guy in the bog.
That sounds exciting.
No.
The sun's coming off.
I think it's too late.
What's new with you?
Ran into some goblins in the wood.
Aw, man.
Yeah.
Um...
You know, I'm just gonna wait.
I wanna get out of my bounty.
Ba-bum.
Ba-ba-ba-bum-ba-bum-ba-dam.
I was over... I... I... Dang it, I was... I need one more.
One more hour.
Okay, he'll appear.
I... I think I heard him.
Good night.
Good night, puny.
I like how this is an abandoned track, but it's not really.
How are you?
There he is.
Good to see you again.
Hello.
Um, can you pay off my fines and my bounties?
You can pay your fines to the guards, serve your time, or pay me half.
Pay me half.
Um, I'll pay off my fines.
Consider it done.
I will get rid of all your criminal warrants.
Yay!
20 gold.
Now I'm no longer a criminal scum.
I mean, just a little bit, but...
Rumors.
If you need something enchanted, Calendil has the goods.
Okay.
Thank you.
Shadow hide you.
Shadow hide me.
I see you're a follower of the Gray Fox, too.
Yeah?
Hot dog.
All right, I'm actually gonna...
Jump here.
Shadow.
Hachu!
Oh my gosh, I haven't had Hachu in so long.
Actually, I don't...
Have you guys ever had Hachu?
They're like a...
Not a gummy candy.
I don't even know what it is.
But...
There's another one.
There's another candy that I actually prefer.
It's very similar to Hachu, but it's got little balls of gummy in it.
It's so yummy.
Yeah, it's like a starburst.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wow.
The red arrow ends here.
So we really gotta go find Falien.
If I were a high elf, where would I go?
A fighting chance.
The merchant's end, maybe here?
Like a Gushers?
No!
It's not...
Yeah, the Puchao!
Puchao!
Those are the ones that have...
They have little...
Little balls of gummy in it.
It's so yummy.
That's the Puchao.
I like it.
It's like Hachu.
But it's not...
It's not Starburst...
Or not Starburst...
Not Gushers because it's not like...
Like a liquid.
They're still...
They're gummy gummy.
Evening.
Are there any high elves here?
Go ahead, please.
Hey, you're the one they call...
The Hero of Kvatch, aren't you?
The one that closed the Oblivion Gate...
And saved the city.
They're so yummy, though.
Farewell.
My...
Um...
Friend...
From...
The UK...
She recently gave me some...
Some...
Candies.
Some of them were Werther's Originals.
Which I...
You know what?
I don't care if it's Grandma Candy.
Werther's Originals?
Those...
Oh...
Those are so delicious.
Oh my god.
But then she also gave me something...
What was it called?
Why is this one the only one that's...
They're so good.
There was one that was like chocolate...
With a little froggy mascot.
It's like called...
Freddy...
Or...
Frog...
Froggo...
Or...
Freddo!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're not our guy.
What's the note?
Go to the end of the street.
Turn left.
Take the next right.
If you see the house with the fallen roof...
You've gone too far.
Knock twice.
Pause again.
Knock again.
They'll let you in.
Be sure to have the money.
Freddos are used by the UK...
As an official economic index.
Freddos!
Yeah, that was pretty yummy.
How do I screenshot in...
Steam?
Like F11?
F12?
There we go.
Oh god.
I was heartbroken when you rejected me.
Tell me what I can do to win your heart.
I will slay trolls.
Walk through thorns.
Fast for a week.
Please don't shut me out of your life.
I love you more than a flower needs sunshine.
Your penitent lover.
The copious coin purse has goods from beyond the shores of Anvil.
All manner of exotic items are available on our shelves.
We have the widest inventory in the city.
Freddo frogs are like the Australia chocolate.
Australia?
Pickpocket!
Guard your purses!
Good night!
Atencion!
Atencion, pickpocket!
Hey!
Uh-oh.
It's all over, Lawbreaker.
Your spree is at an end.
I'll take any stolen goods you...
How did he know?
Then pay with your...
Uh, wait.
There we go.
How did he know?
Oh my god!
No wonder he went back to sleep.
He was like, yeah, that'll get him.
That'll get their attention.
What the hell?
Attention on pickpocket!
If only my mom were so lucky.
One day.
One day in the city.
The main ingredient.
Okay.
We're just gonna keep looking around.
We're looking for Ophelion.
Oh, are you Phelion?
Please say yes.
Carwen!
You wear the shadows well, fellow thief.
Oh!
Phelion!
Phelion.
Yes, I know who he is.
But I'm really not in the habit of discussing such things with strangers.
Oh, you wanna bribe?
But pay off my fines about it.
I don't have any rumors.
Vanivia Melisaia takes all the merchant complaints in the city.
Okay, hold on.
All right.
Oh, that's not bad.
That's not bad.
32.
Goodness gracious.
Okay.
I remember how to do this, I think.
Uh...
What nonsense!
What a dumb joke!
Wait, yeah.
Really like this one.
This one's okay.
Well done.
Yes, yes!
Whatever you say!
Okay, okay, okay!
What a dumb joke.
Uh, this.
Sorry.
I don't get it.
Oh, shoot.
I think I messed up.
What a great...
Not...
Yes, yes!
Oh!
Whatever you say!
It went up, it went up, it went up.
Um...
Uh...
What nonsense!
Don't.
Please.
I'm sorry.
Well done.
Sorry.
I don't get it.
Okay, 65.
I think, what, we need to get to 70?
Uh...
You think that's funny?
Oh, shoot.
I think I messed up.
Why am I so bad at this?
Well done.
Yes, yes!
Don't try to manipulate me!
Ah...
Oh, no!
I can't do anymore.
I messed up.
I'm gonna have to buy this.
For me?
You shouldn't have.
I'm with you.
Completely.
Oh!
They like me now.
Falion.
Falion, you say?
Yes, yes, yes.
Well, yes, I know who he is.
Rather distasteful fellow, actually.
Oh, good.
I'll kill him.
I believe he lives at the Tiber Septim Hotel.
That's in the Talos Plaza District here in the Imperial City.
I'd ask around there if I were you.
Nice!
Hi!
Thank you!
Shadow hide you!
Alright, nice.
Good info, good info.
I have nothing to say to you.
Shadow hide you.
Here?
Nope.
I think we gotta go to another district.
Run, run, run.
Uh...
I'm trying...
Yes.
Maybe that's why they put you there.
So that you can talk to that person.
Sounds like you played Assassin's Creed too, Meantle.
I haven't...
Never, not even once.
Let's go, my athletics.
Here.
Wait, what time is it?
2 a.m.?
We might be able to kill him in his sleep.
Hello.
Welcome, friend, to the Tiber Septim Hotel.
I am Augusta Alidia, your hostess.
Wow, she's so friendly.
Should I talk about Falien?
Yes, I know who Falien is.
Know quite a bit about him, actually.
But I probably shouldn't gossip.
I mean, we hardly know each other.
Not yet, Augusta.
If I can call you that.
We'll see.
Oh, we'll see.
Guys, I have to... I have to go to the little ghostie's room real quick.
One moment.
Give me a second.
Let's go.
To the little ghostie's room.
We are B.
I'm back.
Uh, did I?
Sorry about that.
Thank you for all the super-duty guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for the gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right, let's...
This one is tough, you guys.
This one's pretty tough.
She's only at 40.
She looks like...
Didn't she...
Wasn't she smiling before I left?
Let's see.
She hates to be admired.
Let's do...
Colors.
Whatever you want.
This one she didn't like.
Yeah.
Don't talk such rot.
This one...
I doubt it.
Then this one she was okay.
That's pretty good.
Okay, here we go.
51.
Nice.
Save first.
That's right.
Exactly.
That's...
Yeah, that's probably a good idea.
You too.
That's pretty good.
What can I do for you?
Vorn, welcome to membership.goo.
Uh, let's...
I'm listening.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
Oh, this is really bad luck.
Okay.
I doubt it.
Oh, this is really bad luck.
Oh.
Good one.
Uh.
No more.
You're...
Don't talk such rot.
Oh, I think we just upgraded, though.
That one wasn't great.
That one was not great.
Not now, not later, not ever.
I accept.
I have no choice.
Not bad.
Not bad at...
I doubt it.
Ah, I think I went down.
Oh, gosh.
I doubt it.
Wait.
Don't waste your flattery on me.
Oh.
No more.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Ah.
Hey.
Hard.
This is so hard.
And now it's only...
I think it was plus 10 disposition before, wasn't it?
34 gold.
She's a tough crowd.
Could temp drop the scales.
That works for me.
Let's see if she does it now.
Oh, I know him.
Oh.
A waste of life, that one.
He lives here, you know, with his sweetheart, a trainer.
A trainer.
What that poor girl sees in him, I'll never know.
A trainer pays for their room, their food, everything.
She's quite wealthy, I believe.
Falien used to have money.
Used to be quite a gentleman, too.
But that was before he took a fancy to the...
You know, the skooma.
Oh, the skooma.
He's not using skooma or wandering the city looking for some, I imagine.
He comes back every night to be with a trainer.
But only for a few hours, I swear.
That high elf is going to wind up dead if he keeps living like this.
Oh my god, she spilled the tea so easily.
Holy cow.
She was like...
At first she was like, oh yes, I know a little about Falien.
Oh yes, he's quite the fellow.
And then as soon as you get her, her, her, her, uh...
Um...
Oh, uh...
I keep wanting to say personality.
Her, um, friendship up.
She's just like, that, that love life.
Good day.
Good day to you, Augusta.
What the?
Was this guy always here?
Breaking it down?
Oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops.
Oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops,
oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops,
oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops,
oops, oops So is he here?
Why was he breaking it down like that?
Or is he...
We have...
A poltergeist.
I believe.
What's up here?
The study...
What?
You wouldn't find Faily in here, that's for sure.
Okay.
It's the birds and the bees.
Oh, he's finished.
That was fast.
Okay, let's try one of these doors.
I just want to see what he looks like.
Wait, what time is it?
Okay, it's 3am.
Got it.
Faily...
Oh...
Nobody's here.
Faily in!
I'm also a...
Oh, whoops.
Itina!
Itina can maybe relate.
Wait.
What?
Why is there nobody here either?
Okay.
I thought these rooms were rented.
That's why...
Oh!
That's his girl!
You think I can talk to her?
Good morning.
Yes, my lady.
How may I help you?
Where's your man?
Faily in?
He...
He's my sweet.
My true love.
But...
I don't know why I'm telling this to you.
I mean...
We hardly know each other and all...
You want me to kill him?
I'm listening.
Oh no.
She's even tougher than the...
Than the other lady.
Faelian needs some sleep.
Or...
Whatever her name is.
I'll...
Let's see.
Really now?
You're such a charmer.
That's cute.
You think I'm afraid of you?
I doubt it.
That's pretty good.
Okay.
I got some more.
Says at the bottom.
Oh!
Adrena!
Ooh!
What a wonderful compliment.
Good one.
Oh!
I messed up.
I doubt.
Don't make me laugh.
Ooh!
I messed up.
Talk tough.
There we go.
That's pretty good.
I doubt.
Okay.
Can't do better than that.
Let's see.
Let's see if she'll now talk about him.
Please.
I...
I don't mean to get emotional, but...
I feel I can trust you.
Yeah, you can.
I just don't know what to do about Falien.
He's Falien.
All he cares about is Skuma.
What?
He was a fine young man once.
But he's lost everything.
His looks, his money, his self-respect.
All he cares about is Skuma.
I followed him a few times to see where he goes.
He walks around the city looking for Skuma.
And then he goes to Lorkmere's house for several hours.
Oh?
It's in the Elfin Gardens district.
I think the house is deserted.
That's why he goes there.
So he can escape from life and do his Skuma.
Thank you for listening.
You're a good friend.
I just hope my sweet Falien can clean himself up.
Or that awful Skuma will be the death of him.
That's where he goes to do his Skuma.
I can't...
They couldn't have chosen a different name.
Goodness gracious.
Oh great.
I hope we don't catch him in the act.
Okay, let's go...
To where he is...
I guess...
The Elfin Gardens district.
You have my ear.
Despite the patch, we are still getting some incredible jank this street.
For real?
What's happening?
Oi.
Here?
No, no.
No, no, no.
This place is occupied.
Speak.
I'm so bad at following the arrow.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oof.
Nope.
Here.
Haha, easy.
This game truly makes a lot of clippable moments.
Do you think he's doing the Skuma?
Is he in the basement?
No, maybe he's upstairs?
Who's Lorkmare?
Wait, he's not here.
Oh, I thought that was a coin.
Um...
He's doing Skuma in the basement.
Okay.
Oh!
That's not him!
Uh...
I came across a crime!
Oh, shoot!
Oh, come on!
Seriously?
What a waste.
Oh, wait.
It said it was empty.
Am I bad?
I guess it's already been...
Looted.
Um...
Is nobody gonna report this?
Okay.
Uh...
Well, he's not here.
Big ol' watermelon.
Okay, uh-huh.
Yeah, don't do Skuma, kids.
I thought he was just like, you know...
I thought he was all...
S...
Scoomed out.
I don't know.
5 AM.
I was probably...
Too late.
Um...
Maybe we can wait.
Nothing.
Maybe we, like, wait all day here for him to come over.
But it's probably gotta be in the middle of the night, no?
Hmm...
Wait inside, maybe?
Yeah, let's...
Because it said that he...
It said that...
Well, she said that he goes...
To her at night, his girlfriend, and then leaves in the middle of the night.
Didn't she say what time?
I don't think it was specific.
Maybe I...
Just wait...
Six hours?
That's it?
Okay, that's what you said.
Hey, whoa!
You shouldn't sneak up on people like that!
Hey, hey!
How...
What are...
What are you...
Doing here?
You're not my...
Not my friend?
What?
You know...
What...
Do you...
Want?
You shouldn't sneak up on people like that!
Maybe I should've waited for him to go to the basement.
Dude...
This is what hap...
This is what you look like when you're on Skuma!
Come on!
I want your soul, Falien!
It's time to sleep!
Sleep?
But...
Nah...
No...
I...
I'm not tired...
Not tired right now...
I have lots of...
You know...
Energy...
The Skuma...
I can feel it...
In my veins...
Oh...
Okay...
Oh, this is good actually...
Oh...
Take it...
Come on, Falien...
Go downstairs...
Yep...
Go down...
No...
Go downstairs...
Yep...
Falien!
I think I have to kill him, guys...
I think I gotta kill him...
Oh
shoot...
I did it!
Falien is dead...
I killed him in Lorkmare's house...
A secure location with no witnesses...
I must now return to the Sanctuary and speak with Ochiva...
And receive my reward and bonus!
Yes...
Now that you have him alone...
Is it Falien Isolation?
Can we get Skuma or...
Oh...
Gold...
Lorkmare's house key...
I don't think we need that...
I...
I can hit him in pretty easily...
Yeah...
Why is Tootie so freaking beefy?
Everybody else is...
Everyone else is like...
They just fall apart...
Wait, what is this?
It's Skuma!
Oh...
I could sell it...
It was actually worth a pretty good penny...
Any more Skuma around here?
I'm...
I'm itching for the Skuma!
Any more?
You got any of those...
I can't believe he...
He didn't even have it on his person...
He just leaves it here...
Anybody could take it...
He killed a man for the Skuma!
You know what?
It's fine that we killed him...
Try some...
Hold on, I'll save...
And then...
We'll try it...
Skuma...
Drain...
Agility on self...
Damage...
Intelligence on self...
Fortify...
Strength on self...
Speed on self...
For 20 seconds...
But our...
Intelligence is...
Forever damaged...
Does it make the screen all...
Like...
Loopy?
That'd be fun...
Take all three!
For a change...
The last of the Daedra...
Have been driven out...
Priestesses...
Anyone looking for work...
Should consider the Fighters Guild...
No!
I hear they're always looking for...
So I've heard...
Have you heard any word...
About the other provinces?
Don't be the last to read today!
Black hole is Korea!
There is so much happening!
No!
Makes you quick but dumb...
Speedrunners drink tons of it to go fast...
No kidding!
That's crazy!
What does intelligence...
They didn't go in here...
Did they?
What does intelligence have...
What do we need it for anyway?
Gulp!
Gives you more magic on...
I see... I see...
Afternoon...
Have you ever spoken to Gryond Garana?
I find her annoying...
Oh wait, I forgot that we have...
The...
The better key now...
Hold on...
Oh...
Says a lot about speedrunners, doesn't it?
How do you speedrun it?
Well, I guess...
You know...
If you don't do all the side quests...
Just speedrunning a game like this...
Seems intense...
Oh...
Achieveaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa...
Goodbye...
The High Elphalion now...
Swims in the maelstrom of darkness...
At the feet of our dreaded father...
A hundred gold...
...Sythus...
And there were no witnesses to your handy work...
The Skuma Sippers here...
Hey!
Because of the discretion you exercised...
Captain Phyllida will not suspect the Dark Brotherhood was involved...
And will not meddle in our affairs...
I think we...
I don't think that guy needed help...
Here is your reward and bonus...
To die...
Both have been well earned...
Go now and rest...
And may the Night Mother guard your dreams...
Like, I think that guy could have just died on his own...
Wait, what was my bonus?
More money?
Guys, we've barely made anything...
We've barely made any money...
Why is Tootie's Sexiest so beefy?
I know you guys keep saying Thieves Guild...
But these ones are so much more fun...
I like these quests...
Oh, but...
I can sell the Skuma...
75...
We have to sell that at the Thieves Guild, so...
Worth?
Time to sell drugs...
What is this?
Schedule 1?
Oh yeah, I'll try it...
I'll try it out first...
I like that we were just a detective...
Okay, we save...
Wait, no...
No auto save...
Save...
Quick save...
There we go...
Let's try it out...
Well, I don't even feel that much faster...
How can I help you?
Okay, never mind...
Maybe I do feel faster...
Oh...
Have mercy...
Just one coin...
I'm so fast...
What?
Oh, I think it's over...
Hello...
I experienced the Skuma...
Yeah, we were hallucinating people in the bushes...
Cool...
Now that's...
I feel like this entire stream...
We've just been going to...
Uh...
To...
Caden Hall...
And then...
The Imperial City...
And back and forth...
Oh, I got a new bow!
I was wondering what the bonus was...
Is that what it was?
I can't unsee...
Whatever...
What is this statue?
Shadow Hunt!
It's enchanted with what?
It's a bonus!
Plus two...
Click the eye...
I can't...
Turn Undead on Strike...
You consume fatigue while drawing a bow...
Oh, wait...
I'm a journeyman...
You can focus your vision...
Oh, yeah...
Oh, okay...
Yeah, that's right...
I gotta get to Expert...
Have a slight...
Chance to paralyze the target on hit...
That would be...
Big...
Yeah, I always have a great chance to paralyze...
We'll get there eventually...
Wait, what time is it?
Thanks for asking...
Okay...
They'll be here soon...
Me children...
Are starving...
Wait, what's in the basement?
Oh, I can't go...
I wanna paralyze!
Let's try it out...
Maybe it's...
Fancy...
Who knows...
Me children...
Oh, my acrobatics...
Let's go...
Maybe if I just like...
Practice...
At um...
My shooting...
At like a range...
I can get it up higher...
You know...
Nice level up...
All I do is jump everywhere...
I'm always jumping...
Needs a key...
Aww...
Armand Kristoff's house...
I don't know that guy...
Oh, wait...
I can...
Level up now...
I need to sleep...
Once we...
Once we get our guy here...
We'll wait...
Two hours...
Then we can...
Then we can sleep...
I could buy that house...
But...
I would much rather buy the haunted house...
Good to see you again...
Oh, wait...
Where can I sell things again?
Umm...
He's a captain of the...
No, no...
I don't care about this guy...
Umm...
What was it?
Oh, it was somewhere...
About Thieves Guild is here...
What do you want to know?
Where can I sell?
Where's my Doyen?
The Doyen are the hands and eyes of the Guildmaster...
You take your orders from them...
You get your favors from them...
I am one Doyen...
And Scriva is the other...
Where can I find a fence?
I'm looking for that...
I can't even...
Oh, wait a minute...
Ah, it was the last thing...
That's why...
The best fences are only available...
To the higher rank Thieves Guild members...
Thank you...
Here's a list of who you can use...
Why does he look so sad?
Angar...
Angar lives in Bruma...
Bruma...
Okay, thank...
Oh...
Goodbye, goodbye...
I'll work out my problem...
It's your prison...
Thank you...
Goodbye...
Shadowhide you...
Bruma...
It was like...
Up here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
Shadowhide you...
Doesn't know Armand...
Talks to Armand...
Greetings, Bosmer...
Oh...
Hello...
Goodbye...
He was in...
Uh...
The...
Like some...
Oh, I think it's down here...
Oopsie...
Oh God...
Oh...
I didn't get any...
Fall damage...
He's in some sort of...
Bar or something...
I think it's this one...
I remember...
Well, they're gonna have a skooma problem here soon...
Do you think what happened to Kvatch...
Could happen here?
No...
They were taken by surprise...
Hello...
What can I do for you today?
Um...
You can...
Bye...
Wait, what's our...
What's our relationship at?
Oh...
Not good...
Our relationship is...
What, did you miss me or something?
I've bought from you before...
Maybe not...
Oh...
Bad luck...
I have no choice...
That's...
Don't be silly...
Blah, blah, blah...
What a bore...
On guard, not Olaf...
I really don't get it...
Good journey to you...
Heard any news from the other provinces?
I've heard that Nord warriors have traveled...
I'm really tired...
Can we get on with this?
For you...
Of course...
Oh, that's right...
He likes me...
There...
My favorite customer...
What do you got?
Um...
Haku...
Maybe here...
Let's see...
Nice...
Cruelties are...
It's worth 600...
Wait, what's black band?
I think I already...
I think I'm wearing that...
Yeah...
Base ring of light...
Oh, that's right...
We can have the...
I think we can sell this...
I don't feel like I'm ever gonna use this that much...
Because...
Um...
It won't make me sneaky...
If I really need light...
I don't feel like...
Do you ever need light in this...
Game?
I mean, I have a bunch of torches...
Somewhere...
They're somewhere...
I'll just sell it...
An excellent bargain...
Nice...
Where's the scuba?
Um...
Daedra heart...
Restore health...
Yeah, we'll keep that then...
Um...
Where is it?
Oh...
Did I miss it?
Did I skip it?
There it is...
What else did I steal?
Oh, repair hammer...
But I use those...
We'll use those on my...
Um...
On my...
Uh...
My bow...
It needs it...
But actually...
Wait...
We could probably...
I got this bow...
It's better...
We could...
Have another bow as a backup...
But...
This one...
Like the steel bow...
We can get rid of...
No?
Cause it's heavy...
I think it might be...
Okay to sell it...
Don't really need backups...
But what if I accidentally...
Don't realize...
And use it up...
And it breaks...
You ditch both extras...
Really?
So if...
Say this gets to zero...
Bro...
It won't just disappear...
From my inventory...
I just repair it...
Oh...
Oh okay...
Nevermind then...
Goodbye...
The suffer thorn...
Is worth so much...
Oh my god...
I kinda want...
Can I...
Well I guess...
We could sell this...
This blade...
Yeah...
Kinda sucks...
Anyway...
And...
It says that...
We only had enough...
Langerwine...
For one shot...
So...
Yeah...
I think I can move...
This item for you...
At that price...
Thank you...
Got anything else?
I'm looking...
Gosh...
This is also worth...
So much...
I'm not even wearing it...
I'm wearing this...
Shrouded armor...
It is technically better...
But...
Actually...
I feel like I should sell it...
It's worth so much...
And also...
This gives me better points...
Sell...
Oh my gosh...
This will put us to 3,000 gold...
That was kinda my goal today...
Was 3,000 gold...
You can always buy it back...
Oh...
I guess...
So...
For...
Ooh...
A high, high penny...
Holy moly...
3K!
Yeah...
Anything else I can sell?
Let's...
Do buy this...
Potion of cure disease...
Lots of potion stuff...
Fire salts...
Mmm...
The varla stone...
That I got from...
The one cave...
The single cave...
The...
No, I've done more than one cave...
Hehehehe...
Ah...
Too bad we...
We use these...
But that's okay...
Hmm...
That should be good...
Yeah...
Some people were saying...
It's a quest item...
You'll...
You need to...
You need to sell...
A statue to start a quest...
Oh...
You could hit almost 4K...
Yeah...
Sell a bunch of the potions...
But like...
What if I need them...
Weak potion of sorcery...
I think I will sell that...
Sell to the dark elf...
In the merchant district...
In...
In Imperial city...
For max money...
Really?
Oh yeah...
Why am I selling things that...
To him that...
I didn't steal...
There was one thing though...
That I had...
That said I was...
That was stolen...
Not the repair hammer...
It was like a scroll or something...
This...
House upper wall hangings...
Eh...
Whatever...
I'm glad that's done...
I need a nap...
Okay...
I don't know...
Why would you do that?
He's kind of like...
A guild master...
For the thieves guild...
All I know is...
That the Doyen...
And other senior guild members...
Do his bidding...
Like trained dogs...
Hmm...
Trained dogs...
Shadow hide you...
But our mercantile went up too...
Well guys...
Oh...
Let's um...
Sleep somewhere...
Let's go find...
Uh...
Um...
Let's go...
There should be a...
Like a mages guild...
Thing here...
Right...
Mages guild...
Maybe they have beds in the chapel...
House for sale...
I don't remember what guilds I've...
What I...
What I joined...
Ah...
Brewing my mages guild...
Yeah...
But if I sleep in an inn...
I have to pay money...
Hello there...
Hello...
Here...
If I go to the mages guild...
It's free...
Happy Father's Day...
On this day...
Be sure to tell dad jokes to your dad...
Tell dad jokes to your dad...
Everybody...
Alright...
Let's...
Wooden door...
Okay...
Let's...
Algebra is like divorce...
You look at your ex...
And wonder...
Why...
Oh...
Not here...
Where can I sleep?
Let me sleep...
Let me go to sleep...
Oh, living quarters...
Here we go...
Perfect, perfect, perfect... I
don't think... I don't think Vol... Volanro is actually asleep here... I think somebody... Was about to be caught doing something naughty... Me, when my mom walks in... Trying to play... My... Trying to play Pokemon under my sheets... Selena...
Let's sleep with... Selena...
Can we max... Isn't 100 the max?
Did we just max our... Agility?
Oh my gosh... Let's do more speed... Endurance is what?
A health out of combat... We could get a better personality...
Yeah... We could start doing our personality again... This will help us... Oh, that's right... We can only do a couple... I don't think max strength... Would help with the... Assassins... Because it's only like... Long swords... And things like that... But it does help our max health... This is what... The max agility... Is what helps us...
Do those... Assassins... Those assassinations... Yeah... Yeah... Strength does help with loot...
Or do I do luck?
Oh my gosh... One luck is four things... That's crazy... Wow... Luck isn't worth... Is it bad in this game?
We can go with strength...
Yeah...
We'll do endurance... Next time... Anytime now... I'm not talking to you... Hmm... Luck is pricey... It is pricey... Yeah... How do I get out of this place?
Oh, here we go... Awesome... Well, guys... I think that's where I'm gonna...
Stop... Stop... I think we... We killed lots... We... Did some good quests... Uh... We made it to... Over 3,000 gold... So we just need... 1,800 gold... More... So if we can kill... If we can do that... The last two people... In that one quest... That will make it so that we only have... 800 more gold... That's crazy...
Then we can buy our house... Our haunted house... Uh... Yeah... We killed lots of people today... I pickpocketed... But they were... Fake sleeping... So they actually woke up... And got mad at me... What is it... What is... What... What... Quest am I... Currently on... Oh... Enter the Eliminator...
Accept the contract from Oceiva... Oh... I wanted to do this one... Wait... I wanna go just see what it looks like... I just wanna see what it... Where is it?
Where... Where is this... Bug?
Huh?
Wait... It doesn't show up on the map... Whoa...
Oh...
Wow...
Wait...
I kinda wanna go see...
I just wanna see... I just wanna see... Just a little bit... What it looks like... You know... I don't think we... Have I been here before?
I actually have no idea...
No?
Uh oh... I'm supposed to adventure... To new places... My bad... I'm supposed to not... Hello... Oh my god... Hi...
Oh... Oh... You have a portal to oblivion... Like right outside your house...
Whoa...
It's really boggy here...
Maybe we can just go in and out... Maybe we can kill him... In and out baby... Oh no... You gotta go into a cave?
Oh... No we don't...
Maybe it's just in and out...
This is way less boggy than I expected...
Where's the water?
What are these?
Ew... Bog beacon... It's cute... He's so far... Nah... He's not that far away... If we st... Oh... If we start sneaking over... He won't see us... Maybe... Wait... This way...
Sorry...
I know I said I was gonna end...
I'm sorry... I know I said I was gonna end... But I really did want to do this one... This quest... It seemed fun...
I think I found his... Little campsite... Bog water... Discovered... Oh there he is...
Hey...
What is it now?
Scartail... I guess I've been expecting you... Assassin...
Don't try to deny it... Don't try to deny it... I can see it in your eyes... You're a dark brother... Through and through... Let me guess... You can see it in my eyes... It wasn't Jeeva... Right?
Now... Wait... Tainava... Yes... He put you up to this... Didn't he?
Tainava... And Jeeva was always too busy... To be even bothered... Well... You can kill me... If you like... I'm afraid I won't make much of a challenge... Though...
The Argonian royal court... Already sent an agent to do the job... Yeah?
He failed... Of course... His body's around here somewhere... But he got in a pretty good hit... I'm gonna loot that body... If I don't get some rest... I'm probably dead anyway... So... Maybe I can appeal to your sense of goodwill... Huh?
I knew it!
You let me live... And I'll tell you where I stashed my treasure... Is it a deal?
I should've saved... Treasure?
He could lie... He could lie... Or we get it... And then we kill him... Why not both?
Yeah... I'm gonna... I'm gonna tell him... And then I'll kill him... Yeah... You show... Unexpected mercy... For that... I am thankful...
My treasure... Is hidden in a hollowed out rock... Near my campfire... It's yours... Oh yes... I suppose... Tynava wants proof... That I'm dead... Eh?
Let me guess... My heart... Hmm... I suggest you take the heart... Of the dead Argonian agent... His body's around here somewhere... Present the agent's heart to Tynava as proof... And he'll be none the wiser... I don't believe that though...
I don't... I don't actually believe... That he'll be none the wiser... For some reason... I think he's gonna know... You know?
I think he's gonna know...
Save?
Yeah...
You're right... Wait... Let me... Let me do a hard save too... What we could do... What we could do... Is... Um...
Hollowed rock... Where?
Is... Get the... Get the... Get the... Other... Oh, here it is... His treasure is 100 gold... Is... Get the... Other guy's heart... And then... Um... Present it... And see if it works... You know?
Wow, there's so many Oblivion portals here...
It's by the tree... Here?
What?
Uh... I... I hate to... I regret to inform you... We are in a... A forest... Oh!
Oh!
There we go... So let's try it... Silver dagger... We could sell that... You
have to obtain the Argonian's heart... I must now return to the Dark Brotherhood Sanctuary and...
Yeah... Yeah... Let's... Let's try it... Let's try it...
Hmm...
You could sell all of that... Oh!
I didn't think about it... Eh... It's fine...
Hmm...
Nah...
Let's see... I lied to him... But... Lying's not a crime... Excuse me, brother... Can you spare a moment?
Yes, brother... Let's see...
Just call me Ocelot... Just call me Ocelot... I work for myself... Me alone... Where is our brother?
Lying in court... I... What?
Are we in a... Court of law now?
I don't think so... Since when did the Dark Brotherhood ever follow...
Laws... Aw... Screw you... Hail,
my sister... Of course... What is it?
No, no, no... I have to talk to what I said... So... Ha!
Yes!
That is an Argonian heart... Of that I am sure... You have slain Scartail... Well done... Ah!
Please... Take these boots as payment for your services... Did it work?
They are called the Boots of Bloody Bounding... And carry a powerful enchantment... Ooh...
I am sure you will find them most useful... Thank you... Scartail was once as a brother to me and Nochiva... But his act of treason... Destroyed any vestige of that relationship... His death was well deserved... Damn... May you walk always... In the shadow of Sithis... Dear sister... Ha ha ha ha ha... Getting pushed around by a skelly... Let's put this on...
Do you see the price?
Oh my gosh.
Is that all I can wear?
Oh no.
What do we do?
I also noticed that...
Um... I should probably wear this, huh?
This goes down.
Is it... Can I also use the repair on these to make them the... the effects last?
Oh, I can!
Oh, awesome.
Okay, cool.
Fortify acrobatics on self.
Fortify blade on self.
Oh... No!
This is so sad.
Oh, this is so sad.
Anyway, that's for future Minto.
We completed that quest, so...
Yippee!
They're part of an armor set that was removed before release, so you'll never get a full set.
Your choice.
Nice shoes.
Oh, hey.
Get out of the way.
Hail, my sister.
Aw, man.
Well, if we sell them, we sell them.
If we save them for future armor, that works as well.
But, um...
This is where we will...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why are you glowing?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa!
Why are we...
Why are we glowing?
Oh, it's the armor.
Whatever we're wearing.
Because of the enchantments.
Yeah.
Whoa, freaky.
Freak Tina.
I'm trying to just see her face, man.
Stand clear.
What?
I just want to see her lovely face.
While I say goodbye.
She's a ghost now.
Maybe in here.
It's the lighting mother.
A little bit.
Ah, good enough.
Thank you guys.
For real, for real.
Now, now I'm leaving.
I'm a bit hungry.
So, I'm going to go eat dinner.
Thank you guys for more Oblivion.
And hanging out with me.
I don't know if I'm going to be streaming Monday or Tuesday yet.
But that will be all that I stream this week.
I apologize.
It's a...
It's a bit of a shorter week.
And then there's Off Kai.
I got to prepare for Off Kai.
Super fun and profitable run.
3K.
Plus.
And boots.
Yay!
Thank you, Dorgo.
Thank you, Veriland.
Thank you, guys.
Having so much fun watching all the murder and mayhem.
That is...
What happens.
Thank you, guys.
Take care.
Rest well.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm going to go...
In fact, I'm going to use my...
Throat spray.
And I'm going to go rest.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Thank you, picnic.
Thank you.
Good night, Vito.
Good night, Damien.
Atsumito, everybody.
Thanks for all the fun Oblivion adventures.
I love this game.
Okay.
Atsumito.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye for real.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Wait, let me see if anyone's streaming.
If anybody's streaming.
I don't see anybody.
I don't see anyone.
Okay.
Bye-bye.